it created these dopamine rushes where
like it sucked it sucked it sucked and
then like one of our articles got like a
million views and i got so pumped
[Music]
all right sean's not here so ben and i
are doing this ben producer ben what's
up what's up how you doing sam um so
this episode is kind of special because
i've got people who ask us questions
um okay should we uh should we uh do
some of these
okay
uh i'll read them
and all
as you're answering them i'll go pick up
some of the new ones in case anyone has
responded with more stuff on twitter um
so first one is pretty open pretty
generic what do you want to learn more
about in 2022
um
[Music]
in 2022 i want to learn more about
how to get popular on youtube
that's what i'm going to do and in 2022
i'm going to take more adventures
i'm going to do more trips so that's
what i'm gonna figure out do you have an
answer
uh i do but i actually just wanted to
follow up on the youtube thing
um
you are a self-professed wannabe fitness
influencer is like that a part of it
are you also trying to learn instagram
like where's your head out with the i
want to
vlog i want to keep a diary of my life i
think it'd be fun to look back in 50
years and say yeah like you could see
there's a period of my life that's all
in video and i could watch it and see
how i behaved i think that'd be really
exciting so that's why i want to do it
that's interesting
let's uh
oh yeah go ahead what's yours
uh i was just gonna say like i'm pretty
much laser focused on my podcast right
now i'm growing it but the other thing
that i'm like super interested in and i
think is gonna be a big space
for the crypto type people
uh going forward is this idea of like
startup cities autonomous cities
um like kind of
building a new way of living from the
ground up and people are doing
interesting stuff there with um
there's something called prospero that
you've talked about that peter thiel is
trying to build down somewhere in
central america there's praxis i've
talked to those guys a little bit
there's some interesting things going on
and
i i would like to learn more about that
and see what's happening in that scene
what are some business related uh
or what's an idea and trend that you
think is over hyped
um i'll go first i think it's um
well how about this i'm actually going
to say what i think is under hyped
because that's also part of the question
you know what i think is under hyped
recycling
i think it's i think current ways of
recycling are over hyped so did you know
that the most most of the you know how
like you have a blue bin at your home
yeah that's [__] it all gets thrown
away and burned they don't
almost all of it
like the vast majority like 90 of that
gets burned and they don't use it the
only reason we do that is because it
makes us feel good and so we're okay
buying more [__]
um and that was and i believe that this
whole recycling thing was it was made
popular by a lot of plastic like big
plastic the plastic lobbies
um and
that's [__] so i think recycling is
over hyped i think making it actually
work
is under hyped i'm very very uh bullish
on that and it's something that i think
about all the time
um
i think that's a good one uh i actually
did it i used to work in consulting in
the previous life and
uh
i i worked on a big project with a waste
services provider one of the big ones uh
here in the u.s and i can tell you that
you are absolutely correct about what
you am i
yes
how much of it is just thrown away
here's the thing the big way services
providers um and there are two here in
the us they try they try to recycle yeah
the thing is you actually have to be
like really good with your recycling of
like you have to wash out your milk
carton you know you have to
like
take out all of the styrofoam that is
even if there's little pieces like but
then you need like five different bins
you need like a plastic one plastic two
classic three glass a glass b now in
some areas they will sort it for you
right but
anyway it's extremely costly
um
it's not energy efficient so it like
costs a lot of energy to
recycle this stuff so it's like is it
worth it from a carbon standpoint anyway
and then most of it it's just not worth
it because people aren't that good about
sorting out their stuff and throwing it
away the right way so anyway
you're right about that
but i do think there is an interesting
space for people who do
recycle like if people are willing to
confront the fact that it doesn't work
then
hey can we do some recycling stuff that
does work like can we recycle in a
different way i think it's interesting
space i always say
i always say it should be reduce reuse
that's just end it there don't say
reduce recycle just reduce reuse
yeah
i think it's like i think it's tragic
that i order something from amazon and i
get all that packaging it
it hurts me i'm like i'm why why is it
hurts me just because this is
inefficient but it's like i just took
this from the environment when i didn't
need to
yeah yeah absolutely
um the one i'll say that i think is over
hyped is i don't think it's overhyped
but i do think that you know the hype
cycle where it goes way up and then you
have the trough of disillusionment and
then it comes kind of back up
i think we're right at like the top of
the initial hype cycle for crypto
we're gonna hit like a big
uh
like disillusionment period where a lot
of people are gonna leave the space
and then
it will find its footing and find some
legitimate uses a few years from now but
i think um
that the the current fervor cannot
continue forever
i think i agree i agree
uh
let's answer all right so your your 20
million by 30 goal what was the process
to come to that number so this person
basically when i was like 21 or 19 i
forget i set a goal where i wanted to
have 20 million dollars liquid by age
30.
and the reason why i created that goal
was i basically asked a bunch of rich
people how much they spend each month
and it ranged from like ten thousand to
a hundred thousand a month but this one
guy whose life i really liked i think he
said he said sixty thousand dollars
and
then a lot of like i went through a lot
of monte carlo simulations and what it
shows is if you spend only three percent
of your net worth per year
you will never run out of money and your
principal will continue to grow so 60
times 12 is 720 000
and then um three percent of 20 million
is around that so 3
times 20 million is
600 000 so it's a little bit less and so
i thought
um
20 million was a nice number because it
was close to that 60 000 a month number
and a lot of people think you could
spend 3.5 so that's
the number changed a little bit because
a lot of people say it's 3.5 some people
say four i budgeted for three and i
don't spend anywhere near that i think i
spend like eighteen thousand dollars a
month
do you worry at all about sort of these
black swan scenarios of like inflation's
bad right now at fifteen percent what if
it goes like really out of control do
you prepare it all for
catastrophic scenarios like that
no uh
like the vast majority of my
net worth is in large publicly traded
companies and real estate
um no if i'm bullish on america
therefore i don't plan on its demise
uh all right do you have another one you
want to do or you want me to go you can
go
all right
um
how about this one
i was just about yeah that's what i was
gonna ask too okay what what are you
most proud of when it comes to my first
million
uh uh to this day when people say they
listen to it i'm like really why
so i'm i'm shocked that anyone even
listens to it whenever i get i get
recognized on the street weekly and
that is the most proud so i was going to
bring this up but we talked about ross
albright and he said i wanna i want
someone to bring up silk road to me and
i want them to not know that it was me
i've heard people talk about it or
reference it and they didn't know i was
there or
i say who i am i'll say i'm sam and they
don't know anything but then i'll say
like um oh my last name is par and they
go oh wait you're
from the podcast i love it so that is
what i'm most proud is when strangers or
people i don't know say that they listen
i'm most proud of that can i tell a
story that i was gonna tell the top of
the show and i forgot
it relates to what you just said um so i
i told you like a little bit about this
but we did an ama together about
podcasting i was talking about how to
take over the world and a little bit
about my first million you were mostly
talking about my first million so we're
talking with a group of a number of
people on trends about
podcasting and just at the beginning um
the the host the the moderator asked
everyone to type in
where they were from and one person said
alexandria virginia which is where i
live so i just sent him a quick dm and i
said hey you're also in alexandria
you subscribe to trends you're probably
my kind of person let's go get lunch
sometime this person said uh
this person's we'll call him john not
going to share his identity publicly
john says yeah sounds great i'll dm you
on twitter let's go get lunch sometime
the next day i'm flying to where i am
now utah which is where my in-laws live
and we get on the plane
and i'm there with my wife and with my
daughter who's one
and so we had a aisle and a middle seat
and so this guy gets on he has the
window or no no we had a middle and a
window yeah we had a middle and a window
and this guy had the aisle so i say to
the guy hey would you mind taking the
window seat so that we're not
always crawling over you to to go use
the aisle to walk my daughter around and
the guy says sure no problem a super
nice about it so we all sit down and he
turns to me and goes i'm sorry
are you ben wilson
and i immediately felt cool first time
anyone's ever said that to me and i said
yeah and he said
i'm john like i'm the guy that you
messaged yesterday on that ama and we
were sitting next to each other in the
same row on this airplane so anyways it
was my first time being recognized and
just
like one of the most insane coincidences
i've ever had
what did he say
he said he's a huge fan we talked to
just about like what he's got going on
he had a bunch of questions about the
podcast about what i'm doing but he's
he's an issue he's a really cool guy
it's really interesting when you when
that happens because
you you're like wait you're smarter than
me you listen to our podcast what the
[__] why
it is wild yeah let's let's wrap up with
number six and seven how's that yeah
sounds good what's the most fun you've
ever had in your professional career and
why i don't know what's yours
i've got two answers
one is one time i worked for a startup
that did like event
uh management technology like they did
sort of the software backbone for ces if
you know what that is but so i would
just go around i was single time it
would go around to a bunch of different
like major conferences and events
and that was just like really fun from a
fun standpoint of just like being in
different cities all over the world and
um
just like being on vacation all the time
while i was working i really like that
that's good mine was when i first
started the hustle and i was the only
employee
blogging and trying to game reddit and
get all this traffic was the most fun i
had because i it created these dopamine
rushes where like it sucked it sucked it
sucked and then like one of our articles
got like a million views and i got so
pumped and so that was the most fun
where i was like just writing every
single day in order to get views
i think that was the most fun
uh okay should we go with uh finish up
with number seven yeah so
your cursor's over so you gotta read it
oh sorry name a couple of celebrities or
high-profile business people you'd feel
genuinely nervous about meeting
i was uh when i met tim ferriss i was a
little nervous but i'm not nervous
anymore i would say um when we had
andrew huberman and ariel helwani on the
podcast those two folks i was more
nervous to talk to than anyone else
uh i will
i would absolutely say with ariel you
definitely
were for like days and weeks in advance
i didn't notice so much with andrew but
i definitely believe you
um
yeah and i don't know i i haven't met as
many rich and famous powerful people as
you so i you know my list is long like a
lot of people all of them that's my
answer
no we haven't we've had like some famous
people reach out and say they like so
like uh when sean
sean's now buddies with hassan uh i like
that wasn't that was no big deal for me
like some or like we've had a handful of
like famous people reach out and say
they listen like really famous like tier
one actor famous and i found that to be
incredibly underwhelming um when i met
lance armstrong so basically
um i grew up cycling and i'm a massive
lance armstrong fan and one day i get
this uh email and it's a picture of our
office in austin and we had like a sign
on the window
and
it said hey that's so cool i didn't
realize you guys were in austin and the
gmail sender said lance armstrong and he
signed it just like l
and i hit reply and i go i don't believe
your lance armstrong here's my phone
number call me to prove it
and i get a call and he goes hey man
what's going on it's lance
and it was lance armstrong and i was
like
what
in my mind of like the top 10 famous
people i could meet he was like in the
top three i was a huge lance fan i still
am and he goes what's up dude i was like
nothing you like i was so shocked and
eventually we just talk on the phone and
he goes you want to come over i go yeah
i would like to come over he goes cool
come over for breakfast next week so i
fly down there and hang out with them
and now we're friendly and we've hung
out and gone to dinner a couple times
and i still am nervous around them
that's super wild
it was it's a crazy crate that was the
craziest like
celebrity style moment
um
were you nervous to meet rob a deer deck
at all no not at all
that's interesting because dude i didn't
even want to do that podcast i was like
why are we gonna talk to rob like he's
just a skateboarder like he doesn't do
anything interesting and then on the
podcast he totally blew my mind
but at first i said why are we talking
to rob dierdick like he doesn't do any
interesting business stuff
yeah
all right
something interesting happened recently
so there's this guy named
ross albright
am i saying that right you think
i think so it could be ulbricht but i
think it's albert albrecht
well ross we're going to call him ross
mostly
he
not allegedly but this is the fact
there's a lot of alleged going on here
but this is the fact that i'm gonna say
he started this thing called silk road
and about eight years ago i believe
three thousand days ago and i'll say
three thousand days for a certain reason
three thousand days ago he was arrested
and sent to prison for life
and
basically silk road got famous because
they had something like
if you do like today's dollar it
basically made bitcoin popular because
it was like ebay for drugs and something
like 10 billion dollars went through it
in only two years and he since he
started it and he was allegedly uh hired
a bunch of murder for hires and
for the creating the silk road and for
the murder for hires he was sentenced to
life in prison
and he tweeted out the other day
uh basically this really cool status and
whether you think he's a murderer well
he didn't actually murder anyone but
whether you think he tried to kill
people or not and he's a bad guy or not
it's incredibly interesting content of
him tweeting about being in prison and
he somehow has access to twitter and he
is able to talk about it and then he has
a medium like a blog where he blogs
about death and prison and it's
incredibly fascinating so because he
just tweeted this on december 17th he
tweeted today is my 3000th day in prison
at this point i feel numb to it i've
forgotten what freedom feels like but
when i let myself feel like i am today i
just feel pain and a deep longing to be
part of the world again so like this
like super deep stuff today what i
wanted to do was with ben tell the story
of ross
explain why this story is incredibly
interesting and almost like what we can
learn from business and leadership about
it
and we're going to try and like make an
argument like we'll try to dissect the
arguments of is he guilty or is he not
guilty and i want to
preface this podcast that's with a few
things the first
finding
unbiased information on this topic has
been incredibly hard it's been
incredibly hard because the people who
don't who are on ross's side are like
these bitcoin bros who love bitcoin and
they're incredibly passionate about it
and then of course there's his family uh
who isn't
who says he didn't do what he's accused
of and finding information has been hard
and also the third maybe biggest reason
is there was a ton of corruption in this
case where a lot of police officers or a
lot of detectives were arrested because
there was so much corruption in this
case so i want to say that like we're
using research that is likely biased and
i think i'm biased about the situation i
had a strong opinion about it so
i'll try i think what we should try to
do is say what's fact and what's not
although that would be hard i think it's
a little
i don't know where you kind of came out
on it
for me it was like really easy to put
myself in ross's shoes so i found myself
naturally drifting towards opinions that
exonerated him and i had to kind of
check myself because i want him to be
innocent if that makes sense 100 and
that's what i have at the bottom of this
of our show is for us to talk about like
what our opinion is and one of my points
is it's easy for guys like you and i you
know uh
uh white dudes who
uh have are good intentioned and who
have access to the internet and like
imagine ourselves because that's what
this guy ross which we could talk about
he looked like he was like a tall
good-looking guy
and it's easy for us to imagine that
we're just like him but
like
when i when i lived in san francisco
there was these uh guatemalans on the
corner and they would sell heroin to
people on the street and i was so angry
at them i'm like man these guys should
be arrested what the hell and i caught
myself thinking like well ross said do
it i'm like no no that's [__] racism
like you gotta like it's gotta be the
same either way you could just because
he's like this like intern just because
he's doing it on the internet
you know what i mean so anyway uh we'll
talk about that so let's start start
with the background do you want to go
first ben
sure
so uh he starts in your old stomping
grounds uh he starts in austin uh he was
kind of a science guy
uh
in college he studied um
i wanna say it was something like
neuroscience or something like that but
was more of a sciency guy before he
decides that he wants to go
uh down more of the business
road um
and so
has this kind of flash of an idea uh and
he he kept a diary which turned out to
be not a great idea for him uh if you
keep a diary keep the bad stuff out uh
keep yourself covered but he wrote down
basically everything in his diary uh he
wrote quote uh the idea was to create a
website where people could buy anything
anonymously with no trail whatsoever
that could lead back to them
uh he'd been studying
the technology for a while but needed a
business model and strategy so he kind
of goes into his bunker uh i read like a
thing from his girlfriend at the time
that said he became increasingly
withdrawn and was just like in his room
24 7
programming
coming up with the business model come
up with this whole thing for what would
become
silk road and silk road is this
essentially a marketplace where you
could buy or sell anything initially
they do end up putting some restrictions
on it like no child porn uh you had
other stuff written there what else
could you not do on silk road no fake
degrees
and no counterfeit goods but there's
times where that those rules kind of got
blurred because someone was like should
we have cyanide pretty much the only
reason people use cyanide for is for
killing themselves or killing other
people should we allow that and they
ended up allowing it so there was a
little bit of gray area of what they
allowed and what they didn't allow and
before he started the silk road he had
an online business called good wagon
where he sold books
and it didn't go so hot like at the peak
it made in revenue was like 10 grand in
one month and so his profit was very
little and
at the at the beginning of 2011 in that
same diary he wrote uh well basically he
he
he basically ex admits everything so
about starting it so he goes in 2011 i
am creating a year of prosperity and
power beyond what i have ever
experienced before silk road is going to
become a phenomenon phenomenon i can
never say that word and at least one
person will tell me about it unknowingly
or unknowing that i am its creator and
so he talks about that and even in his
linkedin his linkedin says that uh what
did it say
where'd it go
oh sorry on his linkedin he wrote i want
to use economic theory as a means to
abolish the use of corey
i can't ever say that word either what's
wrong with me use echo how many read
this for me ben
uh
use economic theory as a mean to abolish
the use of corrosion i can't even
coercion
on his linkedin page ross wrote that he
wanted to use economic theory as a means
to abolish the use of coercion and
aggression amongst mankind
so he's basically like acknowledging all
this and so
uh what he does is he learns how to
program i believe he just used
uh like the most basic coding languages
ever and builds this website on this
thing called tor
tor is basically uh it's it's basically
a different version of chrome so it's a
web browser it was developed in the
early 2000s by the us navy because they
wanted a way for
officials who are in
north korea or in china to be able to
use the internet and not be tracked and
so they created this browser and so i
remember when i was a little younger
when silk road was around i downloaded
tor and i went to the silk roads website
and you had to like type in this like we
all these weird numbers in order to find
it and it popped up and it was amazing
like it was like i couldn't believe that
this was a thing
and 99 of well i don't know if it's 99
but most people who used it were using
it to buy weed essentially so like there
was all this stuff around the edges but
the research that they have done shows
that people were generally going to it
to buy small amounts of weed not like
big drug dealers but just kind of people
like sam who were like oh cool you can
buy anything on here i will buy weed i
never bought anything on there just for
the record
we did an article
um uh we did an article about this and
and i had friends that bought ritalin
from it
and they were like kind of squares they
were like not
people they i didn't know that they were
like
they don't put in your head they're not
like a drug user or you know but they
bought ritalin and adderall on the silk
road and i used to go to it i never
bought anything from it but i would go
to it just like i can't believe this is
a thing and
right when it launched he basically grew
some in the book the american kingpin he
they said that he grew mushrooms and put
it on the website in order to get the
initial sales and then he uh somehow
gawker found it like just a few months
after starting it create created an
article about it on gawker.com which at
the time was one of the most popular
sites on the web and that's kind of when
it blew up
and he uh you know
you mentioned his kind of early comment
uh about
like manifesting the growth of this
thing uh he also comes up around this
time with his moniker so uh the system
admin
who we now know to be ross wrote who is
silk road i am silk road the market the
person the enterprise everything i need
a name
and uh then he said my new name is dread
pirate roberts which do you know where
dread pirate roberts comes from a little
bit but tell me it's from the princess
bride
so
it's uh the the kind of the main
character wesley
uh
goes and gets kidnapped by the dread
pirate roberts and then later it turns
out he is the dread pirate roberts and
that dread pirate roberts is actually
like more of a position and so once one
pirate dies someone else becomes dread
pirate roberts and that name's important
because that's like the whole crux of
the case which is are there many people
doing this or just one right so in the
name is seated this idea that there
could be many people who are dread
pirate roberts it like kind of
um hints at that
having said that there is i don't know
if you want to go through it but there's
like pretty compelling evidence that he
was at least the main
person who was dread pirate roberts
let's let's do that but just not yet
let's first get i want to set the
background for finish up we'll wrap up
with what silk road was and like ross's
background so around this time this was
in february of 2012 so we're about uh i
think a year after launch
he starts blogging
on the silk road and you can go and read
some of his writing
his writing is very good he's a very
his character this character of ross and
this character of dread uh pirate
roberts it's very romantic and it
creates like a cult of personality and
he writes things about how we need to
stop funding the state with our tax
dollars and direct our productive
energies into the black market
and he says money is powerful and it's
going to take power to affect the
changes i want to see and it's all about
how like people need to have their own
rights to decide what they want to do
with their bodies things like this like
very traditional libertarian things
traditional uh
what's it called the austrian school of
economics it's like a way of thinking
it's very libertarian
um
and he even writes we what we are doing
will have rippling effects for
generations to come like he uses these
words
that are like he sounds like a a
dictator or and you want to get behind
him uh and he sounds like he's
furthering this like romantic and
admirable cause and in some ways i'm i'm
on board with that because i am on board
bitcoin um but the idea of like
you know we don't want to be controlled
by a central bank things like that i'm
on board with it and he does a really
good job of using that language
it's amazing too
to go back and look at it
with the amount of value that was
flowing through uh silk road at the time
because bitcoin
hadn't had its moment yet the way it has
now and so you can go back and look at
the amount that flowed into dread pirate
roberts's wallet and if you just held it
it's now worth like five billion dollars
or more or more yeah yeah
uh
so
uh yeah so it's all it's
it's booming as you said gawker picks it
up uh there's a lot of money flowing
through it um
and after only two years of doing this
he gets arrested and the way that he
gets arrested is is pretty amazing so
uh basically in like 2010 he writes into
a forum uh stackover stack overflow a
popular development form forum uh
developer form and he goes how do i
connect to a tor hidden service uh using
the curl and php
and then he lists his website as ross
albright at gmail
and so he's like he posts that which
that in itself isn't interesting but
what they noticed is that immediately
after posting that he changes his
username from his name ross albright to
frosty and the reason that's also
interesting is the very time the very
first time anyone used the word or
reference the silk road
it was for a username in a
forum called the shumery.org and frosty
that username he writes something like
hey has anyone seen this cool new thing
uh called silk road where you can buy
and sell anything anonymously so he
posts that and then in another thread uh
using frosty that same username he posts
something saying like i'm working on
this uh site that helps people sell and
buy anything i need help dm me if
interested you know he says something
like that and so that's actually how
they like catch them and they notice
that
this guy ross previously he had gotten
in a little bit of trouble because
homeland security
opened a package a few months prior and
they found like 20 different fake ids
all with his picture and different
addresses on there and they went to his
home and they busted him and he said he
bought him like as a gag and so he
actually got away with it he didn't get
in trouble but they go huh this is kind
of interesting
this guy has a little bit of a
background and they uh end up like
stalking all of his social profiles and
they notice that he's talking a lot of
libertarian stuff on his linkedin he
says uh what he does and what i said
earlier about uh
a very libertarian vibe he watches a ton
of libertarian and bitcoin related
videos on youtube and comments on them
and that's basically how they catch him
and so what they do is they find out
that he lives in glen park and i have a
story about that because glen park is
where i lived he lived right down the
street from me when he was arrested
they found out that he goes lives in
glen park and the police stake out his
house and what they're able to do um is
they're able to track him because
throughout this process which i'm going
to talk about
an undercover agent an agent went
undercover and befriended him and
basically became an employee of silk
road additionally they had arrested
other employees of the silk road
and i'm going to tell you how in a
minute and they were having
conversations with ross because of that
the whole time and what they noticed
when they were tracking him in glen park
they noticed that when dpr
is saying he's going to get off the
computer so when and he tells his
employees like hey guys i'm done for the
day and closes the computer they notice
that ross goes out for a walk and so
they're just able to catch like okay
whenever dpr logs off ross is out
walking around and so what they do is
they go to the library
uh because ross goes to library works
out of life the library this library was
basically like eight houses up from my
house and he goes to the library and he
logs onto his computer and what the
investigators do is they have two of
their guys go behind him ross is sitting
at a table with his computer open
working on the silk road they have two
uh investigators go behind him and kind
of act like two homeless people getting
in a fight and ross turns his back to
his computer to see what's going on and
someone swoops in and grabs the laptop
from out of him and then another person
tackles him and they rush the laptop
down to the uh van waiting outside and
they take screenshots of it and then
they down the the data and he was logged
into the silk road admin account and
everything that they ever want is there
and they could easily see uh how much
bitcoin he had they could see everything
and at the time he had 144 000 uh
bitcoin which
at its peak 60k it's like 8.5 billion
dollars that he had um and so they
caught all of this and they logged on to
the computer they find his diary where
he's like logging all this interesting
stuff going on he's got like a
an escape plan about what he's going to
do if he gets caught i mean it's just
all there
yeah and it wasn't just so they have
this
physical tail on him and they're able to
like using this kind of shoe leather
approach connect him to drip height
roberts
but they also had
did you read how many federal agents
they had infiltrating silk road
no
you want to guess
i don't know 50. that's really close so
60. there's 60 federal agents who were
on there doing like fake sales or fake
buys and bus and a lot of them weren't
even talking to each other right
right and and a couple of them and this
will come into it later
uh
were
like pocketing money were were
essentially like when they were busting
people they were just like well no one
really understands bitcoin so if it just
ends up in my wallet it's fine and one
of them ends up going to prison for that
so we'll let's let's talk about that in
two seconds so but first
ross is arrested for doing that
and everyone's shocked
and i'm gonna i'll tell a story about
that in two seconds but everyone's
shocked and eventually after a very
short amount of time he goes on trial
and he gets locked up
and he they find him guilty and the
judge sentences him to like two life
terms plus 40 years and so
the verdict and then they they appeal it
and they go to the supreme court and
they just say nope we're all we're
holding this up so at this point
very very very very likely he is in
there forever and nothing will ever
happen
and
now like this is where a lot of the
drama begins and the reason why
a lot of the drama begins is because
there's a lot of debate over whether
there was multiple people
as uh dread pirate roberts and the
debate is if there is multiple people
did he commit the hits so throughout
this process there was four or five
different times where someone emailed
him like an employee and tried to
blackmail him saying things like or they
would steal money from him or they would
say i'm gonna reveal your identity if
you don't give me blank and so ross
hired someone or dread pirate roberts
hired someone to go and kill these four
or five people but the person he hired
was an fbi agent and they went to the
people's house and they knocked on the
door and they go
[__] we know you're up to no good we're
supposed to kill you you better
cooperate with us
and they take fake pictures of them
killing these people and in exchange the
people
spill the beans on everything they know
and that's how they get access to be
able to track him so well um
yeah so to be clear
he was never convicted of this
in fact he was never even charged with
uh putting out these hits
um
and that's because they probably didn't
they didn't have very solid case uh it
was gonna be very difficult to prove
that he was actually the one
that did it but
it really seems like the reason they
wanted to put him away for so long
was because they were pretty sure that
he did it they just couldn't prove it
the judge says basically i need to make
an example out of you
she goes we need to put an example to
anyone who creates the silk road too
this is what's gonna happen and the
prosecution actually told the judge we
want 20 years and she goes no no no
we're doing life
and they gave him life
which is wild
and they never actually pursued the
murder charges because or the uh
murder for hire charges
but she does say in her
reasoning for the sentencing that she
takes that into account and she assumes
that he does it
which i don't know like anything i don't
know much about the law i don't know if
that's considered kosher or not but
that's what happened it's it seems
legally suspect to me
that something that you were not
convicted of
could
count towards your sentencing
yeah i don't know i i i do think so
okay do we want to jump into some of the
implications of this and some of our
conclusions so one thing i will say that
scares me a little bit is
essentially
he's being put away for life
for
something that they couldn't prove he
did
like
well that what i believe the charge was
a bunch of drug charges but then there's
this
if i'm not mistaken there's this thing
called the kingpin the kingpin act
something like that where basically um
in the
uh
40s and 50s they were trying to arrest
these guys like al capone and they're
like [__] all we can get them for is
like tax evasion but we know they
murdered people and so they created this
act that basically says that they can
put these guys behind prison for a long
time
even if they they don't know that they
did it but they know that they were
involved in so many things
correct and so i guess how you feel
about that is going to determine a lot
about how you feel about this that
crimes that they can't get them for they
just like you said they kind of add up
these tax evasion charges until they say
all right well we we couldn't get you
for murder but you're gonna be life
behind bars anyways for tax evasion it's
it's pretty wild um and let me tell you
a quick story and then we're gonna go
into like let's let's have an argument
about why we think he's not the one and
why we do think he is the one and i will
try hard to do both but so i've told
this story to you ben a couple times
i've sold on the podcast but since we're
talking about it already i'll bring it
up so
around 2012
i went to a party in san francisco and i
was single at the time and i saw this
girl and i was flirting with this girl
and this very charismatic tall guy comes
in
and kind of steals the girl from me and
i wasn't like mad you know we were just
flirting
but i was in awe of him like i was
charmed by his energy he was like nice
enough and he was good-looking and
confident and he stole her and
i
like looked up who this guy was after
the party and i was like oh his name's
ross oldbrick and i looked him up on
linkedin
and i wouldn't we weren't friends but we
had that one running and he lived on
someone told me he lived on the street
from me in glen park and if you're in
san francisco glen park is a
neighborhood that's a little bit more
family oriented and so if you're young
pretty much no other young people live
out there and i was one of the young
guys and so i heard he lived there i was
like oh that's cool i gotta hold this
guy one day well i
i see that there was a big commotion at
the library in glen park i lived down
the street from the library and i would
hang out there
and i look online and it's this guy i
knew ross had been arrested and it was
four starting silk road and i was in awe
i'm like oh my god and so
we went online i and went and found all
the pictures we had together at that
party and we i took screenshots of all
of them and then we had to delete all of
them because you know everyone was
nervous we're like
so
after this party when you look him up
like what did what did people think what
was the public face of what he was doing
like what did you think he did who did
you think he had
so
i think his linkedin
like the description said what it said
up there i think it also said that he
was a currency trader or some type of
like currency
uh
i don't know anything about that world
of finance but it made it it was
interesting bitcoin wasn't that popular
at the time and in fact the day after
i told my friend billy i go billy
my uh this dude i know was arrested for
silk road your dad likes bitcoin right
billy his dad was tim draper who
eventually goes on to buy
the bitcoin he i think he was a
billionaire already but he bought the
bitcoin that ross was uh arrested with
because they the government auctioned it
off and that bitcoin is like worth like
five billion dollars and he bought it
from the government for like 20 million
or something like that and
i go billy
this is crazy and he goes yeah my dad's
and at the time he didn't know that his
dad was gonna buy it but he was like
yeah my dad like loves bitcoin he thinks
it's like the future and i was like
all right that sounds cool i don't know
anything about it but if
this is just too good to be true like i
gotta like you're telling me you think
it's gonna be popular and the guy got
arrested i'm just gonna buy some and
that's how i bought it and i and i
bought bitcoin for my family that year
for christmas
so
if you were attaching a percentage
chance to it what do you think the
chances are that he was the one who put
out the hits for higher
so you think he probably did but you're
not totally sure
so yeah let's get into it so there's the
problem with this case is that there's a
large amount of
information out there that's really good
for both sides
and it's really hard to know who to
trust
and so
i don't know like what's not debated is
that he started it the point is like
when did he give it up and so let me
explain to you why i think it's suspect
so he had this friend named richard
richard bates and rich he tried to
recruit richard to come work at the silk
road when he first started it and
richard's like no i'm not into that man
that's illegal
eventually ross wrote to him and said
all right i sold the site
but in the diary he wrote i've been
lying to my friends and telling them i
sold it
so
that has happened a bunch of different
times and
it's hard
and what we forgot to mention was
throughout this case
there's like three or four different fbi
agents or like dea agents who are
convicted and go to prison because they
started talking with ross and getting
into bitcoin and they eventually like
started feeding him information about
what the feds were doing and they
started stealing bitcoin and they were
locked up and sent to prison for this
and so there's a massive amount of
corruption going on here but
you could say and his parents say
because there was so much corruption we
can't trust the entire case i actually
think there can be corruption and it can
also be true for example o.j simpson
mark furman i think planted that glove
um so you know the the if it don't fit
you must have quit they were they found
this glove and o.j simpson's thing and
but they're like why is this glove here
and like i think mark furman planted it
because he was racist but also oj killed
that lady right you know what i mean i
think a conspiracy can exist and also
the guy's guilty yeah
i i think so
one of the big
points of debate is did anyone else have
access to judge pirate roberts
it seems clear that other people at
least at times
a few other admins did have
access
but there probably weren't multiple dprs
if that makes sense like he was dread
pirate roberts but maybe some other
people have limited access for a short
amount of time
the other like
question is
did
once the fbi and the dea had access to
his laptop and had access to dread
pirate roberts
could they go back and edit messages in
order to make them
support their case essentially and he
argued that they did
and there are some people who were
involved with silk road who basically
say yeah i went back and looked at my
messages after the fbi had access to
ross's laptop and like my old messages
are totally whack i didn't say any of
that stuff now they might have reason to
say that stuff anyway but that that is
an argument yes but
there's things like that which make me
question it and then there's things like
this so listen to this this is a post
that ross wrote
there's been more than one occasion
where i've wanted to quit without
getting into details the stress of being
dpr is sometimes overwhelming what keeps
me going is the understanding that what
we are doing here is more
is more than uh more than my more
important than just my insignificant
little life i believe what we are doing
will have rippling effects throughout
many generations there's gonna be a
shift in how human beings organize and
relate to another one one another i have
gone through the meant to listen to this
i've gone through the mental exercise of
spending a lifetime in prison and dying
for this cause i've let the fear pass to
me with and with clarity commit myself
fully to the mission and values outlined
in the silk road charter
so he writes things like that and i
think so are you just you're lying to
all of us
well in a little bit it's like if you
believed in something that strongly
and what he's saying is like this
glorious revolution
then would you would you be willing to
kill for something that's that important
definitely yeah i mean it sounds like
the kind of rhetoric that
maybe maybe so let's talk about uh some
more evidence that shows that he uh that
he didn't do this so there's no doubt he
admitted that there's this great website
called free ross and i'm not saying i
actually agree with it but it's called
free ross and then they have a post
called like the true story and they
someone on the on his team wrote all the
this really long blog post and it has
all evidence citing everything that they
said
um and basically in that ross has
admitted he goes yeah i started it but i
handed it over uh someone a hacker came
to me and he said um
like i figured out how your site works
i'm gonna get into it because of this
error you made uh otherwise you should
just sell it to me and so he does or
that's what they say the story is and he
sells it to the guy who started mount
gox do you know what his name is
uh i'm looking i'm trying to look it up
right now so he sells this to the guy
basically mount gox in 2012 was in 2011
2010 was coinbase but back then
um eventually this guy though
gets locked up and goes to prison
uh because
mount gotts gets gets hacked and he kind
of knew about it and so he's kind of a
[__] crook i mean this guy's a crook
hardcore but what the police say and the
feds say they say that
silk road was registered on a
domain service owned by this guy and
that most of transactions that were
working with silk road went through
mount gox and it made sense for the
mount gox ceo to want to own silk road
because it increased the price of
bitcoin and made them more valuable and
so that's a huge accusation here
mark curples is yes
is the name
so that's what a lot of people so a lot
of people think well he actually wasn't
it and then they go well why did why was
ross on on silk road when he got
arrested they say because
this guy hired ross as a freelancer
after he sold it for help and multiple
people had access to it and so they say
yeah he was helping him run silk road
when he got arrested but he's not the
guy who ordered the murder for hire or
did a lot of the other stuff
yeah i read
i met a guy the other day who lost 20
million dollars
in the mount gox hack
sheesh
and that guy the mount cox guy he's a
french guy he spent time in prison for
doing a bunch of bad stuff in japan so i
think that guy's sleazy
um
it is sort of a just so story though
that like oh yeah i was totally out of
it but
i was doing this one last freelancing
gig you guys happened to catch me at the
exact moment when i just happened to log
in for one last time just to help this
guy out
it is uh it does stretch
credulity a little bit it does
uh but there's so many things in the
story and we're only touching about a
little bit of it there's a book called
american pink kingpin there's so much
stuff in this story though that
is like it's hard to believe is true but
it is in fact true like
basically when ross started this in
2010-11
he was like a happy-go-lucky-ish like
uh oh you know i'm down on my luck i'm
gonna try this and then within 18 months
you see his tone changed to like being
this like domineering we're gonna take
over the world and further this cause
type of guy and this is just like i mean
this is it's a movie just how this guy
could do it and he had the good looks
and the charisma so it's hard to know
what to believe because there's a lot of
unbelievable stuff that's true
yeah exactly and also add to the fact
that
by virtue of what he's trying to do most
of it is secretive by design so it is
like hard to unravel and unpack what is
true what is not
because it's intentionally obscure
and um
and so i don't and then add that it is
just so weird though to me that like
multiple
federal agents multiple multiple federal
agents on this case
get arrested and do in due time do hard
time
for
corruption and one extortion
one guy who did it i think his name is
carl force i think he got sentenced to
76 months so like what's that like six
years
uh
he basically you can go and read his
chats and
i think that he like fell in love with
ross
and this idea like uh like fell in love
with the idea of like this this mission
and he would he would say like dude
you're gonna get arrested i'm gonna get
fired from this i'm gonna go to jail for
this i think that like he at first he
wanted to make money but because this is
such a romantic like idea of
overthrowing the government and like the
little guys are winning and we're doing
this all and we're the downtrodden they
all bonded together and it was when i
was reading this i was like i wish i was
part of this
and so i understand it so this guy knob
he that was his username carl force's
username on silk road he
just did it for fun and just to learn
and then he realized like he got into it
so i think it was a combination of greed
so he eventually stole from people of
greed but also i think that they just
got caught up in the intoxication of all
this because when you're doing something
like this it feels like there's no
consequences when you're building
something online it's like well this is
just fake like there's no consequences
yeah so
let's talk about how big this was so uh
the silk road even though it had a
massive impact on bitcoin and society
and things like that it was only around
i think for two years and so
and let me see if i have some stats so
between there was a period between uh
may and july where 1.2 million messages
were sent on the platform
um when he was arrested he had 144 000
bitcoin which at its peak is like 8.5
billion dollars and keep in mind he was
only it's like ebay you only take like a
10 feet so that's like not including the
that's not the transactional volume so
in 2013 uh they say that it was doing
more than seven million in income so dpr
the that was his his his annual revenue
or his and so there's with these
businesses there's gross merchandise
revenue like or total transaction volume
which is like if your ebates how much uh
goods are going through but then there's
like how much the actual company makes
because they only take a 10 fee and his
10 fee added up at the time he was
making seven million dollars in bitcoin
and if you uh
if you bring that out to today's prices
that means he was making around five
billion dollars a year
already in year two and
there's a bunch of interesting things
about this the first is that he was
doing all remotely without knowing the
identity of his co-workers so he
eventually hires like freelancers but
they and he like makes him do certain
things like
um
send them his their id and stuff like
that and but he had like a team and he
didn't know at all who they were and it
was all done remotely that's incredibly
interesting they built something that
big that fast that that way and second
um
uh he didn't know how to code he was
learning to code as he was going yeah
that is
that is kind of mind-blowing it is
interesting that he was able to do it
with this remote team that he'd never
met but like half of them ended up
trying to extort him right yes yeah so
maybe a cautionary tale there in terms
of who you work with
but like
oh well sure but it was a productive
working relationship other than that
huge thing so if it's like a thing where
there's like where it's like well no
like
we're we're selling um
bottles of soda like i can call the
police on you like it's not like i'm
afraid to call the police on you about
this thing totally
um the numbers by the way uh
so
in terms of
this is like dea estimates so they say
1.2 billion dollars worth of illegal
drug trans transactions took place is
that at the time of bitcoin's price in
yes not current day price that is at the
time price
so then i i think bitcoin when he was
arrested was worth around
80 or 90
and at its peak it was 60 000 so
so what's that you multiply it by 6 000.
yeah it's a lot of money a lot a lot of
money
uh in in today's value
um
so 1.2 billion dollars
uh
46 million of that is marijuana 17.4 is
cocaine 8.9 is heroin
uh then how much
1.2 billion in
in then time
uh money total moved oh my gosh i can't
even my calculator i'm like struggling
to even
it's hard to even read those numbers
it's basically like 780 billion dollars
so
it's crazy right it's crazy like the the
how big this is
i would love to see some numbers i don't
know if you have i don't have them of
like
of um
what percentage of
bitcoin transactions
back then and even up till now took
place on silk road it's crazy
so the reason why they suspected it was
mount gox was when they started it
accounted for like 75 of mount gox's uh
business
um so let's talk about why
this story is so fascinating so the
first reason is like there's just like a
lot of like drug sex and rock and roll
like this is like we're we're into that
no problem admitting it the second
reason is that for a lot of like white
nerdy tech internet guys of which both
of us are that this guy ross is
incredibly relatable
we look at them and we're like oh i
could see myself doing that
maybe not going that far but like i i in
in some regard i would say we're envious
of him we're like oh man he had the
courage to like do this epic thing
because it doesn't seem like there's any
bad consequences to what he was doing
even though it's not realistic but
that's how it feels and it's also like
it tugs on your heart strings a little
bit of to look at a guy who you're like
yeah he's kind of like me and he's never
gonna
breathe a free breath again for the rest
of his life
like it's just hard to digest that that
like
because
let's take for granted that he did call
in these hits right
like it feels like someone who just
really got caught up and got really
carried away and i know like we both had
to check ourselves like that's not
really an excuse that's not fair that's
incredibly unfair it's incredibly unfair
to people other people who do get put
away for these kinds of things
but
it is like easy to to relate to and to
excuse
if you're someone like us who has an
easy time putting yourself in issues
another reason why this story is
incredibly interesting and it's this is
the part that hurts which is that it
feels like ross's life is like a wasted
life so this guy was like
kind of i wouldn't say he was a genius
but he created something amazing and it
only lasted two years and now he's in
prison forever and it's just like
a total waste that's why i feel angry
about this i'm like man this guy was so
smart he had it going for him what the
[__] man
now he can't do anything
yeah and also i feel like his life is a
little bit of a waste and silk road is a
little bit of a waste like
you know obviously some really terrible
stuff happened on it i think
and i don't know how much i agree with
like
hardcore heroine and stuff movie but
like at the same time i don't know if
you're if you are someone who has a
little bit of a libertarian streak
you're kind of like well
shouldn't there be room for something
where people can like
do stuff outside of the all-seeing eye
of of the government you know so i went
through this same battle as well i
consider myself to be aligned with a lot
of libertarian stuff and i realized i'm
not a true libertarian because i don't
want drugs to be legal
and if i don't want them to be legal in
real life like i lived in san francisco
and i would see these guys shooting
heroin all the time i found a dead body
at my office once did i ever tell you
that no so uh i was at my office
uh i got in early at like 8 30 and
there's often times people sleeping at
our door
and i would nudge them with my foot i'd
be like hey can you you got to move
please i got my employees are coming you
can't lay in our doorway and i did that
and the person was i did this time the
person was dead
uh from drugs
and we would see [__] like that all the
time i lived in soma
and i would see the drug dealers they
were allowed to be there i knew who they
were i could tell you who they were i
know i knew that a little bit of the
background i would like hear him talking
and i was so angry at them i was like
these guys are the worst for our society
they're only hurting people this is not
good
and i think so that's when i changed i
was like i don't want heroin to be legal
i don't want this to be legal this is
not good
and
i was so mad at these guys and then i
found myself romanticizing ross so much
and i had to check myself and say this
is wrong it's wrong on both sides if i
don't like these
these uh these uh gangbangers selling
this [__] i can't also
think that ross is innocent or should
shouldn't suffer
yeah absolutely i get what you're saying
i mean i'm not a true libertarian either
but i don't know i it's just like
i can't even think of a specific use
case for it but
just the idea of there should be a place
that isn't owned does that make sense
appeals yeah yeah yeah i agree
that's why that's another reason why we
like him so much is because we like his
intentions were interesting
yes
so you did your research for a little
while what is your opinion
on if he's guilty or not well
on a bunch of different stuff there's
actually a lot that i want your opinion
on okay um
so we we
you you believe that he started it
obviously he admitted that do you think
that he was uh running it the entire
time yes
so then that means do you think that he
ordered those hits
i do i maintain that there is a
possibility
that um
that no that at least the chat logs were
massaged in order to
make it look more open and shut
man i like
i think that a person would do that the
problem that i have with a lot of
conspiracies is
when many people are involved in
something keeping a secret is impossible
keeping a secret is very very very hard
if there's three or four people involved
particularly government official
government officials it seems like
keeping that type of secret is so
freaking hard so if that did happen
there had to be more people involved
and
did did there though i mean i guess
would one person risk their career just
multiple people did that's the thing you
know they did it
they did to make money yes most of them
yes what do you have to gain by changing
this
just a guy goes to jail i don't care
about him a person that much well you
got to realize though that for some of
these prosecutors and for some of these
ea agents like this is a career-making
thing like i'm the guy who busted ross
albright and sent him to jail drug
kingpin billions of dollars worth of
transactions like
you're you're kind of made right after
that right so yes i do think they had
something to gain from it
it is a little conspiratorial i don't
know i don't know that i would assign a
more than 50 chance that that actually
happened but i think
i
like to maintain like a 30 to 40 chance
that maybe something like that could
have happened
do you think that he deserves life in
jail
no well
ye if it um i don't know i guess
yeah if he did try to call hits on
people multiple times
then yes someone who does that does
deserve to does deserve life in jail
yeah i guess so the reason why i'm a
little suspect if at first i thought
that's fair but then i realized no one
died no one actually died
and for murder a lot of murder for hires
um
particularly if if no one dies
they don't get life
because
you know they get 20 years
and so it is crazy that he got life and
there's also a lot of cases i listen to
a ton of crime stuff where people
actually kill someone and they don't get
life and they are can get out after 25
years and so you have to ask and i've
spent time in prisons working with a lot
of people i've met uh inmates who killed
their mom or killed their killed someone
in their family killed their wife and
they get out after 20 years because
they've proven that they're
rehabilitated and when they did it they
were like young-ish and they're like we
think you could deserve a second chance
did you read the chat logs at all
well there so that's another thing about
this case is
there's like so many chat logs like
there's like thousands and thousands of
pages so which ones i've been talking
about specifically the ones where
um
he supposedly orders the the murder for
hire yeah he was pretty callous about it
yes but
uh the other side who i believe did turn
out to be a federal agent is that
correct
yeah
he's like kind of
drawing him into it a little bit like a
little bit yeah of like man this is such
a problem i wish there was a way for it
to not be a problem you know and is like
definitely trying to move him in that
direction i think ross says like let's
just beat him up and the guy replies
with i don't know if that was gonna do i
don't know if that's gonna solve this
yes
which is like pretty shady especially if
you think that's a federal agent like
man why are you trying to bait this kid
into ordering a hit
so
my opinion is i think that there's so
the thing about like trials though like
you have to you have to paint a picture
of a shadow of a doubt
i have a shadow of a doubt
but i think that it's likely that it was
him
i do think that he deserves time in
prison 10 to 20 years just for the drug
charges and for creating silk road
um but i think it's kind of [__]
that the judge sentenced him for the
murder for hire or took that into
account without actually trying him for
it so i think that's a little nonsense
so i my opinion is yeah he's totally
guilty it's just like
how much stuff is he guilty of and in my
opinion it's enough to get 10 to 20.
um but if they wanted to do life they
really should have they had to charge
him with murder for hire and prove that
it was
it happened yeah
do you think so it's uh like early 2012
it's like right in the middle of silk
road going gangbusters do you think that
there is any
and there are 60 dea agents infiltrating
it they're on his case they're uh like
monitoring his house do you think
there's anything that he could have done
to have
either like gone legit somehow and like
turned it into a marketplace for
things that were maybe questionable but
not totally illegal or is there a way he
could have just remained undetected and
and outsmarted
the feds
i think there's a world
where he could have gotten away with it
if he bailed
i think he could have bailed and gotten
away man like
there's a lot of examples like whitey
bulger you know whitey bulger yeah he
was um basically the character that uh
robert de niro is it rapper de niro
in the departed
jack nicholas jack nicholson which one
yeah yeah that's right
he was a gangster in boston
he got enough loot he got like the
equivalent of like 15 million dollars
and he goes i'm out and he left boston
and he moved to santa monica and he
lived there relatively peacefully for
like 30 years and then he was arrested
when he was like 90.
and i think there's a world where like
ross could have done something like that
where he could live um for a little
while maybe the rest of his life
undetected if he just stayed uh
with a low profile but i think a guy
like him and myself included i'd rather
probably die than like shut up forever
yeah
is there a way he do you think he could
have like kept it running from some
small island in the caribbean or off the
coast of africa or something like that
well aren't there still sites like this
are there
i don't think
i'm pretty sure there's nothing at that
scale i don't know i haven't actually
researched it but uh for for the hustle
we had a guy
talk about using medicinal lsd to help
him with his depression and we did an
article where he just showed how he buys
it online and i actually saw him buy it
uh and it was on a a competitor
well i think a lot of this is changing
just in that
the the drug war the idea of a drug war
has taken a hit and so
a lot of people are less gung-ho about
enforcing this kind of stuff
and so there are a lot of places now
where you can you i don't lsd that
probably does have to be pretty black
market but there's some like gray market
stuff where you can buy
shrooms and other kind of
lighter psychedelics
yeah for sure and it might be illegal i
mean you could take ketamine and you can
go to a doctor and get ketamine in um
new york and a few other states i
believe so um
yeah it's an interesting story another
interesting thing is that his girlfriend
she still lives in
in austin so she's a major part of the
book that i took a lot of information
call from called american kingpin she i
think her name is vivian and you could
follow her on instagram she's like this
beautiful black lady uh
she kind of looks like my wife to be
honest and you could like follow her on
instagram and
uh it's really cool because if you read
the book or learn about him
um you you can go and use web archive
and see pictures on instagram
and on facebook and things like that
that like it's what the author's
describing and so you can like kind of
track this journey you're like oh man
here he is see they're under the golden
gate bridge they took that picture like
there she is and you could still follow
her i think she just got engaged i
follow her on instagram
before anyone thinks that sam's just
being conceited because you literally
did just say she's super hot she looks
like my wife uh the first time i saw
that picture of
of her with ross i i did go is that
sarah like she does look a lot like your
wife
yes yeah she does uh
i actually don't know what race this
lady is but she's definitely uh
i bet she's mixed half white half black
that's what my my wife is and it does
look like you're from afar and it's cool
you could see all these pictures of them
together it
what a crazy story so i don't know where
do we go from here
uh
don't do drugs don't sell drugs uh
that's our official advice don't start a
marketplace where people can buy and
sell drugs
yeah
it's a it's a fascinating story um the
book american kingpin have you read that
no i haven't read it um it's the
greatest book i've ever read
it's it's the number one best book i've
ever read it like i was so impacted by
it like it's it's a story that sucks you
in i couldn't set it down
it's amazing
um
it's so good so read that
and uh that's that i wonder if people
are gonna like these the style of
episode i i think they will i think it's
kind of cool uh turns out yeah that was
great
all right is that the pod
i think that's the pod
[Music]
you